[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Olivier Hainaut pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste
messieurs les ministres madame monsieur
le rapporteur madame la Présidente de
commission chers collègues nous y voilà
nous abordons la toute dernière ligne
droite de ce texte sur la réforme des
retraites notre groupe Union centriste
votre âme majoritairement ce texte
mes premiers mots seront pour dire que
nous avons le Sénat la majorité
sénatoriale était à la hauteur de
l'enjeu sourd à la démagogie vous savez
la démagogie je vous écoutez chers
collègues dont le triomphe est passager
les ruines éternelles disaient Peggy
j'irai même plus plus loin le Sénat la
majorité sénatoriale a donné le la tel
un diapason sur ce texte l'occasion bien
sûr de saluer de remercier nos
rapporteur pour la qualité de leur
travail et leurs connaissances du
dossier retraite ils l'ont démontré tout
au long de du débat de la CMP et puis
encore à l'instant en commission
sur le texte lui-même mes chers
collègues je persiste les signes il ne
mérite pas toute cette indignation qu'il
suscite il le justifie pas non plus un
enthousiasme démesuré ni le diable ni la
mère des réformes un texte et ce n'est
pas rien qui assure la survie de notre
régime par répartition et surtout un
texte qui évite à notre pays de
s'endetter pour payer ses retraites
souvent nous entendons dans cette
émission qu'il y a une bonne dette et
une mauvaise dette je partage cette
opinion s'endetter pour investir dans la
recherche dans les infrastructures bref
s'endetter pour l'avenir s'endetter pour
innover peut avoir une dimension
vertueuse mais sans d'été pour le
fonctionnement c'est irresponsable et
c'est compromettent l'avenir cela nous
est interdit d'ailleurs dans les
collectivités territoriales sous peine
d'être mis sous tutelle mais pour moi
pour nous s'endetter pour payer les
retraites c'est le comble de
l'irresponsabilité c'est une honte pour
les plus jeunes générations
cette affirmation toute simple donne
sens au vote de ce texte j'ai entendu
beaucoup parler chers collègues pendant
cette discussion et puis même à
l'instant et cette citation de
Shakespeare me revenait les mots ne
payent pas les dettes chers collègues
les mots ne payent pas les dettes ce
texte
donne de la solidité pour plusieurs
années à notre système de retraite par
répartition notons les avancées je vais
assez vite parce qu'elles ont été
abordés la question de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la question de
l'emploi des seniors avec un dispositif
d'incitation des trimestres excusés du
peuple pour les tuques les aidants les
élus qui gagnent moins de 1830 euros par
mois la pénibilité et puis les carrières
longues avec C43 ans mais alors pourquoi
ce texte avec ses avancées ce texte qui
au total concerne si Français sur 10 et
pas ceux dont les métiers sont les plus
pénibles pourquoi ce texte suscite-t-il
autant de tension nous y voyons
plusieurs causes notre système de
retraite est injuste mais c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il y a eu la réforme Touraine on
vous a peu entendu sur l'injustice du
système de retraite et donc ce système
de retraite est injuste il les moins à
l'issue de cette réforme mais il faudra
encore continuer à avancer vers plus de
justice une autre cause c'est que nous
attendons peut-être trop de de réformes
des retraites une réforme des retraites
ne peut pas corriger toutes les
injustices de la société française de
notre système social et enfin et surtout
la cause de ces tensions pour notre
groupe c'est le manque de dialogue
social et la crise du paritarisme c'est
selon nous la faute originelle de
l'exécutif d'avoir enjambé les corps
intermédiaires c'est pourquoi nous
appelons à l'ouverture d'une conférence
sociale après le vote de ce texte les
sujets sociaux sur la table sont
importants et nombreux le travail valeur
contrainte on en a débattu tout au long
de de ces derniers jours la rémunération
des salariés le cadre de gestion de
l'assurance chômage l'employé seniors et
encore beaucoup d'autres la santé le
logement sur toutes ces questions la
société française a besoin et cet
apaisement passe par l'imparitarisme et
a dit la langue sociale refonder et
rénovée voilà mes chers collègues pour
conclure je veux vous faire partager mon
sentiment différent de ce que j'ai
entendu à l'instant sentiment d'avoir
vécu un beau moment par le menteur un
vrai moment parlementaire ici au Sénat
nous avons fait honneur mes chers
collègues au bicamérisme le Sénat
représente les territoires et c'est son
honneur le Sénat représente les
territoires et c'est son honneur mais
nous avons apporté la réponse la plus
forte à ceux qui nous ont parfois
caricaturés en Bundes strat nous sommes
un parlement de plein droit et surtout
un pilier de la République vive le Sénat
vive la république mes chers collègues
je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]